[Music]
[Applause]
just think and speakers ladies and
gentlemen um good afternoon on behalf of
the urra and design Singapore Council
team um we would like to you know say a
great welcome to ur Center and today is
the first forum for the president's
design award forum and through the Forum
we thought you know it would be a great
opportunity for us to come together and
hear the insights you know to be shared
by the designers now today the theme of
The Forum is people at the heart of
design so you will find that you know
across the different scales of the
projects awarded um all these various
projects have demonstrated that the
designer emphasis on designing for the
people and Community um for example you
know the design team at state courts
have demonstrated right you know not
just being a landmark in the city the
state uh the state cour though most of
us wish that we will not need to make a
trip there right but the the state cour
did offers the opportunity to offer the
sense of relief you know for the
occupants and of course the the office
workers using the project um likewise um
for Capital spring even though it's a
commercial mixeds development in the
city you know many of us including my
two children you know they are delighted
you know to find such generous Sky
Gardens you know built in in the city
I'm sure you know Brian's visiting young
children from Copenhagen will also find
you know fascinating trying out the
different Hawker food in in in cap
spring uh I'm also very inspired by you
know kin's Hair Care project that seeks
to empower
you know this mindset in people that all
of us can make little changes you know
to improve the community and the life of
many last but not least we I I am very
excited and looking forward to hear from
Kenny you know to share his thoughts and
uh not only he's a role model to many of
us but he is also you know having a
great collection and body of works of
both local and international
projects right so therefore um and last
but not least ID like to thank Kai you
know for agreeing to moderate the
session after the individual sharing so
I hope all of you will feel as inspired
as me as we hear from the designers uh I
know you are here to hear from the
designers so I will hand the mic back to
Lyn to introduce the speakers thank
you today we will discuss the topic
people at the hearts of design we will
hear from the designers on how they have
put people and communities at the heart
of the design process to build a better
quality of life and to create a more
sustainable and inclusive Society the
first speaker is Mr Brian Yang partner
from Bak in go group who will speak on
the design of the Year Capital spring
Brian joined big in 2007 and was named
partner in 2015 with a background in
Energy Efficiency research as well as
economics Brian brings an additional
focus on environmental and economic
sustainability into his projects He has
been the project leader on several
competition winning proposals including
the copen hill way to energy plant in
Copenhagen that doubles as a ski slope
and the Lego house most recently he has
been a partner in charge with the
competition winning scheme for the vava
field harmonic Hall in pra Brian
[Applause]
please thank you for the the very
generous introduction um and and I feel
very privileged to to be here here today
I can see um so so this project was
delivered um of course not just by by
big but with our local Partners I can
see Nina L who's sitting in the audience
today with her team from RSP and um
she's always been very generous and
eloquent in acknowledging the the fact
that it takes um a ton of people to do a
project like this so we also just want
to acknowledge um their role in in the
project as well as our many other
collaborators and our clients at Capitol
land as well and and I think one thing
you you definitely realize on a on a
project like this when you show up at
the building site and there are 900
people daily working on it is how it in
a way really puts you in your place and
you understand that it's not just your
project but it's really everyone else
who is putting the the time and effort
and and energy into it that has a piece
of it as well and and really this idea
of architecture and its potential as
something that connects people to
something larger than themselves to to
communities around themselves has been
at the heart of this project and from
the outset we were really trying to to
understand both the the role it could
play as a piece of of tropical urbanism
a piece of the the kind of
infrastructure as in in Singapore but
also given its importance as a site in
the historic center of the the central
business district and how it could
really contribute to the the different
communities around it's part of a really
if you if you look at it a network of
different green parks and and areas we
were trying to imagine how it could be
something that could begin to connect
these green areas together that could
become a kind of true extension of the
the public realm not only in the in the
CBD but again to to start connecting to
some of the areas further a field so
there was a starting point that was a
really kind of rigorous analysis of its
situation in plan how it could be
connected seamlessly to to um sheltered
and shaded walkways um weather
protection in Singapore of course very
important how it could extend paracity
in the the city center be connected to
to Future initiatives such as the the
larger cycling Network and
really um what we realized in the in the
beginning because it occupies the site
of the former Golden Mile um uh sorry
not Golden Mile Golden Shoe Golden Mile
very important building one of my
favorite buildings in Singapore but
Golden Shoe uh but Golden Shoe it's a
huge fulla um Golden Shoe car park which
was built in in ' 84 and at the time to
to Really provide parking capacity for
the the city center but had had also
become a bit of a wall you could say in
the in in in the city in the CBD over
time as we understood had also become a
place that was really occupied more from
the the hours of of 9 to5 so there was
really a lot of thought about how the
the project could be something that
increases paracity on the site begins to
to rejuvenate the the site in the in the
surrounding area one of the the first
things we realized realized is that the
the site itself because it is
Amalgamated over a series of historic
sites has kind of a bit of a a strange
shape in in plan and required a
substantial amount of of cleaning up we
we looked at this is just a small subset
of of some of the the schemes that that
we had looked at over time from a kind
of massing perspective but really the
the starting point was a kind of
exercise in understanding how we could
clean up the site how we could extend
paracity in the site and and what would
mean for the the tower and and it turns
out that the the solution for us was
relatively simple which was to take a
kind of Imagine a tower core to to
offset a floor plate to a kind of
efficient and Optimum depth and then to
Simply rotate it to maximize how it fits
in the the site with a relatively simple
geometry so it takes a kind of diamond
shape which also happens to to mean that
because it's rotated off axis provides
generous views for everybody who would
occupy the the offices in the the upper
portion of the the tower uh so the upper
portion of the tower is offices the
lower portion is occupied by service
residences and what this meant also is
that it would allow us to then occupy
the perimeter with rooms to to create a
kind of internal Atrium space around the
the core um and then to but but
basically also to give everybody very
very generous views outwards from the
the
site so so we had a kind of sense of of
what this would mean in terms of the the
planning for the tower and and and then
we began to imagine what this could mean
in in section and we thought what if we
imagine that the offices as a in a way a
kind of generic block that is elevated
as high as possible to maximize the
commercial value of the offices what if
the the service residences are also
imagined as a as a kind of generic block
that sit connected on top of the the
podium so they could have access to
recreational and other amenities
and that would give us some room to
begin to play with the tower in in terms
of the specificity of how it touches the
ground of how the service residences
touch the offices and how it touches the
sky what if in a way because it had this
diamond shape in plan we began to play
with the geometric versus the the
organic and then we began to fantasize
and to dream a little bit about what it
could mean as a kind of example of
tropical urbanism to bring um the the
kind of lush greener into the the tower
at at various levels of course this
would also have to work with the the
facades uh which would be glazed at some
points maybe more much more open in
other points and then we thought since
it sits in the historic Central business
district some great examples of
modernist architecture what if we simply
took a classic modernist pinstrip facade
brought it from top to bottom to unify
the the tower in a very very simple
gesture and then to begin to pull it
open to reveal the green and the social
spaces that sit with within the the
tower itself as a a kind of invitation
to the surrounding Community to look
inside the tower and and to be invited
up to enjoy the the different
experiences that the different in a way
kind of like public realm and and
Parklands that exist in a in a kind of
three-dimensional way um I'm sure you've
seen the the um this uh this project but
I thought it could be interesting to
also share a little bit more about the
the kind of internal green spaces we
really had this idea of of a kind of 30
meter high tropical jungle or or garden
space within the within this this this
kind of midsection that also was an
exploration of the different layers of
the the rainforest that in a way could
also be programmed in a kind of
continuous loop of circulation from on
top of the service residences with
amenities such as cafes and other
hangout spaces related to that to more
formal workspaces that sit connected to
the bottom of the the office towers and
all of this interspersed with um with
the kind of tropical exuberance of of uh
The Greenery now what happened was we we
brought this idea to the the urra this
project went through a Dap process and
the and and the first thing they said
was um we are deeply concerned about the
survivability of the Green in the heart
of this Tower because at some places it
sits underneath a 17 m overhang in a
deeply shaded area and and Singapore
while there's a there's certainly a
reputation for Greenery growing
relatively easily in the the urban
context um there was there was a lot of
discussion about the fact that we didn't
just want Greenery to survive but to
actually Thrive so it actually meant
that we developed an entirely new
process that was based around
understanding the access of light to the
spectrum of light they use for
photosynthesis called um
photosynthetically active radiation it's
offset a little bit um from the visible
like spe spectrum that we're that we're
all familiar with so there was there was
a kind of very iterative design process
that we had to come up with to
understand the the meaning of the the
planting plant the plant selection and
how it would develop over time so this
is a kind of analysis overlaid on top of
the the bottom level of the midsection
of the tower called the green Oasis
where this analysis allowed us to
identify different plant types that
could be placed in different areas um
from from trees to shrubs and different
types of of
creepers where the idea then if you look
at some of these images we started with
a continuous spiral of circulation but
the final form is arrived at because
they are almost carved out by access to
to daylight so when you're there you can
almost see and and understand how the
voids are created not as um a kind of
aesthetic respon response to the to
creating an interesting Park scape but
actually as a response to the need for
plants to have access to daylight in
order to to survive and it creates this
kind of incredible pinti space where you
have views both looking up and and
looking down as well and a very kind of
dynamic experience as you circulate
around the midsection of the Tower and
I'm pretty happy to report that at least
the times that I've been there it just
gets more and more green even in the the
kind of deeper spaces at the at the
bottom so it certainly feels like it was
a kind of um productive process for us
and to to to go back to what I was
saying in the beginning the the way
we've seen this project and the role
that that it should play in the in the
city is really as a kind of extension of
the the public realm as a kind of series
of three-dimensional Park Scapes that
extend from the the ground floor all the
way into the the sky and I thought we
could just end by by going through um a
few images so you could kind of see the
how that is is deployed in the the
project from the 51st floor um where
there's a again a kind of continuous
spiral of of gardens that that circulate
all the way um around the the top that
also integrates FNB establishments the
an urban farm is integrated into a part
of the the rooftop that Prov that
generates about 80 kilog of produce a
month which is then used in the three
FNB establishments in the the tower
which for for for us has been a pretty
incredible metric to to understand just
the potential of what you can do with
relatively scarce resources in terms of
how it can be a part of a kind of
productive life of the the tower the
Ecology of the tower the the kind of
Economics of the the tower and it's been
so successful that as I understand the
the the restaurants have now asked to
over to take over the entirety of the
the rooftop to turn it into an urban
farm that creates produce for the again
for the the various restaurants um is an
incredible 360 degree views at the at
the top that is completely free for
Access one thing that was very very
important for us was to also return the
original Market Street Hawker Center
back into into this development um it
really has a strong history in this
location as as really the the only kind
of cheap accessible food that had had
been around for a long time so it was
very important for us that this was
returned and connected directly to the
the ground plane when when the the
project opened again and you can see how
the the facade begins to to open up at
the various levels and integrates access
for different types of amenities and
uses and very importantly for us also at
the the ground plane where we have also
pedestrianized uh neighboring a portion
of the neighboring Market Street as a
part of the the Redevelopment of the
area so that it really becomes something
that becomes pors open and and
contributes to an active City and
streetscape thank
[Applause]
you thank you Brian for the wonderful
sharing next we have design of the Year
heck care tips and trick tips and tricks
for a dienal friendly home representing
head care architect hong King director
of leer Architects and Mr hanw
co-founder and creative director from
lakia Andy lacer Architects is a
multi-disciplinary practice that
explores the social emotional potentials
of design the studio searches for
designs that help people to learn and
grow and form more inclusive kinds of
collective relationships alongside her
role as director of leer Architects King
is an associate professor and Bachelor
of architecture program director at the
National University of Singapore's
Department of
architecture anakia NY established in
2010 is an internationally renowned
award-winning Design Studio based in
Italy and Singapore the studios's work
includes research projects for Herman
Miller limited edition objects Mass
products for Brands such as living
Divani and capalini as well as special
commissions for Major Brands and museums
representing lakia and Y is the director
and co-founder Hanway King
please
[Applause]
uh thanks so much for having us um come
today to tell you a bit about ha care
dementia according to alzheimer's uh
disease International affects 55 million
people worldwide currently and it's a
number that will double every 20 years
and I've strived my entire adult life to
try and keep work and family separated
not very successfully I must admit given
that my husband is my business partner
so it's a bit funny to me that this
project in which my personal and
professional lives came crashing
together ended up being one of my
favorite this interest in dementia was
not just academic for me but deeply
personal my father suffered from fronto
temporal dementia for almost two decades
which not only gave us some intimate
insights but provided a kind of fire and
a purpose a quick disclaimer hat care is
not endorsed by Ikea because of
liability
reasons so here you see myself and Josh
hun and our client POA thean Foundation
now hun of lanan who be speaking after
me is one of our closest friends an
amazing designer whose work we admired
and we always wanted to work together
and with PA w we had already done a few
projects he's an amazing instigator
always throwing down challenges and we
started talking about this project in
2016 he knew we had an interest in aging
he knew about my father's illness and he
said why don't you make a different
class but for dementia so so a different
class 10 preschools redefined was a
proposal for 10 Design Concepts for
preschools and it was given out to
policymakers school operators stat
boards Architects Etc to inspire new
designs and to change the way we think
in Singapore about what preschool design
could be and it really did inspire a lot
of Architects and preschool design in
Singapore it was also available to
download for free uh and we managed to
do it so quickly we were turning out one
school design a week so we knew as a
team we wanted to work on dementia
project together to inter uh sorry to
interrogate the interface between the
environment of the home and dementia and
we also knew we wanted to make it a book
because books can travel easily and
deliver ideas far and
wide so the project was supposed to be
provocative done very fast perhaps
taking a year at most easy after all we
delivered a different class in less than
six months it ended up taking us until
the end of
20120 so haare was born out of a
frustration that we had as design ERS
with the state of current dementia
design guidelines now design for
dementia guidelines all tended to be
very high
level perhaps the most famous of these
is the evidence-based dementia enabling
environment principles by Professor
Richard Fleming and Kirsty Bennett and
they're all really important guides but
a bit hard to know how to apply and we
wanted ours to really be within reach so
it's a 240 page book in the Guides of an
Ikea manual to help people adapt their
homes for their loved ones with dementia
and with dementia affecting so many
people most will at least spend the
initial stages of the disease at home
besides sudden and abrupt changes in
routine and environment can really speed
up decline so it's really best to
Dementia in place so to speak why Ikea
well from our own experience at home we
were already using a lot of Ikea
products because they're so accessible
with my father's type of dementia you
start to lose the meaning of signs so
there was a while that my father only
recognized water meaning water that he
could drink by the type of glass it was
served in luckily the type of glass that
he attached the idea of water to was
this kind of JX Tumblr that Ikea has
very similar glasses to you can see the
pokea on the right so we got a dozen of
these and put them everywhere he would
go in our homes at my aunt's home
because otherwise he would refuse to
drink and dehydration is a very common
and dangerous issue or when we needed to
use mattress protectors we found that
the shower curtains at Ikea were cheaper
more waterproof and more durable than
commercially available mattress
protectors so turning to Ikea made sense
all of this is downloadable for free at
hack care.org and close to 3,000 hard
copies have been given out to healthc
care providers caregivers and people
with early
diagnosis there's also a mobile
version um sorry I missed something
there also a mobile version uh where all
of the content okay this clicker is a
bit delayed um is conveniently
accessible now the book uh contains hack
ideas and essays and provocations that
give people insight into dementia and
how the environment can play an enormous
role in caregiving the tips and tricks
are also contextualized within some
understanding of cognitive decline and
how one's relationship to the
environment changes along with the
progression of the disease demonstrating
through practice the principle of person
Centric Care Now the goal was to help
people to think creatively and flexibly
to make tweaks to improve the way they
care at home we had observed how my
father in his decline into dementia was
incredibly responsive to changes in his
environment and more importantly that
the manipulation of the environment was
really in the hands of us his family and
not in the hands of Architects and
designers we realized that many
caregivers were constantly hacking
Sometimes using their own ideas and
sometimes through the sharings in
WhatsApp groups and the adjustment is
constant what helps is to develop a
mentality of constant tweaking to
routines and the environment as needed
adapting to the the progression of the
disease we sought uh Collective wisdom
we spoke with professional caregivers
psychologists geriatricians and
Community dementia care experts we
listened to a lot of personal stories
visited homes looked at the kinds of
challenges dementia poses then came up
with tips and suggestions that Co cover
daily activities now the work really
started by thinking about furniture
hacks and H will talk later about the
process of creating these prototypes but
I want to give a little bit of
background to this we visited Ikea with
carers from the brah Center talked about
which Furniture would be useful like the
classic prong chair how it is in so many
homes comfortable and affordable but for
older people with declining muscle
strength rather difficult to get out of
it also made sense to us as a first heck
as many people suffering with dementia
spent an increasing amount of time
sitting so the the chair became a
significant focus in the home the chair
had to become the center of life such as
drinking water napping being cared for
spending the day so we looked at how to
adjust the chair to enable all those
things how can someone nap here uh
without their head bobbing around can
hire hand rest help them stand up so a
hex gave us this prototype and we have a
shopping list and an instruction
instruction manual for it but as you can
see perusing all the other hacks what
we're trying to do is not create one
definitive solution hacking as a method
isn't about a final design product so
much as an ongoing process of optimizing
and adjusting we feel that this is much
more appropriate to a disease and a
condition of care in which the
challenges are constantly shifting and
each person's dementia journey is unique
you may have heard the saying you meet
one person with dementia and you've met
one person with dementia the progression
and presentation of dementias all varied
are linked to the patient's premorbid
personalities I won't talk about the
other tags as hun
will we then moved to the scale of the
room embedding microw worlds into the
rest of the home we experimented with
Furniture setups to see how they could
be accommodated into some typical living
room sizes how the arrangements of
furniture within rooms can evolve and
adapt to the needs of the person with
dementia and always keeping them
embedded in family life we tried to
address other more intangible concerns
like time how do we cue our loved one
that it is dinner time we looked at the
role of smells Lighting and Sound and
then coming back to the shower curtain
as a mattress protector starting point
we looked at product that might be used
in different ways so from a previous
design research project on Aging
friendly neighborhoods we learned that
many Singaporean Elders are
uncomfortable using Mobility AIDS even
if they need them they don't like how it
calls attention they find it
embarrassing so they prefer to struggle
unaided lean on umbrellas or push
shopping carts instead so in hack we
looked at ways in which Ikea products
might be misused like in this elevation
where handlebars are disguised as a
series of everyday decorative objects
see the line in red there uh yet provide
guidance from A to B or the fidget board
for example made from an Ikea chopping
board fitted with simple Hardware
fixtures or a tote bag or even a
pillowcase fitted with zippers or
eyelets and
laces now the book is deliberately an
optimistic approach to a very serious
and depressing
reality having a loved one suffer with
dementia is an immensely difficult
experience to go through caring for them
yourself makes it even harder getting
the tone right was really important we
wanted this book to spread a
Manifesto to empower persons with
dementia and their caregivers it's a
reminder that we're not alone and that
there are some simple things that can
help alleviate some of the everyday
difficulties and these ideas should be
free shared they should be empowering
and they should expand the discourse and
now I'll pass the mike
toan
so um my name is hanai and the great
thing about this is that how I got to
know them as friends was because I was a
moderator of a PDA session 2016 I want
to say say hey you guys are doing cool
stuff oh you're doing cool stuff too
let's talk about a project right and
then the project came into existence
next year in 17 right um so how we got
into this project was because we did
this collection of uh rethought elderly
Furniture called um No Country for Old
Men which is quite a violent movie if
you know it but quite a nice title if
you use it this way so so it came from a
provocation where you know when we grow
old um we don't have Choice over the
things that we own which is strange you
know because now I can choose from so
many jeans but when I grow old there's
only five wheelchairs seven walking
sticks right and those Define our
relationship with the environment with
how we interact with the new reality
right so so we decided to to delve into
that as you know the the chair is is
symbolic of of daily ritual right
everyone has a favorite chair the chair
is one of the most powerful things you
can show in media to help people
understand a concept right so this chair
obviously has been in production since
um the 1970s so we needed to find uh
Ikea products that do not go out of
production if not the hack would be
rendered uh
futile and as you can see you know it's
really a place where where it's a micro
it kind of grounds this
microarchitectural site in your home and
and if you dementia the world becomes
smaller and smaller and small and small
that's the nature of of this of this um
of this
disease right so so it was super fun
because we all know this chair and and
as a industrial designer right we also
know how these things are made um and to
hack like a classic was was such a was
such a such an honor as well and and we
had to figure out like economics you
know what is upright because a lot of
things are designed for that but not for
that so there was a lot of testing that
we had to do uh in the studio right and
you can see the head rest right 02 up
there is actually the bamboo chopping
board you can buy from the kitchen
section right so it was it was kind of
like like jazs you know like Punk a punk
approach to it uh um to how we were
designing things and and I think that's
how we we saw design you know it's it's
not defined
by um domain but more of concept concept
decides what comes in
right yeah so we had this this term
called uh living chair you know so the
life is all around satellites around the
chair and that's something that that um
you would have to reprogram your
domestic spaces
for yeah so so it's it's kind of in
plain sight you know it's using the the
vernacular of of Ikea you know which
everybody knows and love you know it
doesn't ostracize you it doesn't say
you're weak it's not aluminium you know
it's not plastic you know it doesn't
treat you like like a piece of meat you
know it's you're still human right at
end of the day some you're dealing with
a loved one so as you can see the the
unrest are actually from a famous stol
right you kind of hack together um but I
I I think just to EO what what what
Shing was was saying is that it's not
prescriptive right it's more of adopting
a mindset that you can do it too which
is not prevalent in the Top Line High
principle uh
dementia um advice of of today right so
so it's it's more about redefining what
designs used for or rather using re
using the design method to change
mindsets and therefore Empower because
that's that's the thing that that you
don't really have when when you're fac
in this situation right so you can see
the back support ped armrest you know
things that you could s by yourself so
doesn't have to be exclusively Ikea you
know it's just the system you know it
could be a good morning towel you know
it could anything that has that has uh
emotional value to the user as as as
what Shing said about the derx and the
and the Ikea um equivalent
yeah there you go 990 if you if you you
can do it now as well you have a pong
you find yourself falling asleep yeah
and next we talk about the elot so so
this is is a shelving system right they
can create a little micro architecture
around it there's the blinds attached to
it there's a packboard right so there
there's a certain facing to and
depending on your floor plan you know
you can you can uh face it in the way
that you want right and that's a
beautiful thing so please go and have a
look at at the at the
publication
um and you can see the memories close at
hand before after and we also take care
of the car's Corner because car fatigue
is a real thing right if you care for
elderly that's a real thing so at the
back you can still do your emails you
still do your zoom while still be in
sight of of your dad your
mom right and this is all scades right
everybody knows scades right and and one
of the great things um about Ikea right
is that it's worldwide
right so it's not Singapore and that was
something that we thought of since the
beginning right how how do we take a
what what is global what is familiar
where is a place that I would go to even
don't like who flips through a Furniture
catalog other than Ikeas who goes to
Ikea not for furniture you know it's
it's mindboggling right so so as a
concept as as a as a ecosystem Ike has
all all these things and it's Global
right like when I was studying in
einhoven I had to go I I went to Ikea to
eat breakfast because it reminded me of
Singapore
right for real like yeah I want the
meatballs and the Lincoln Berry sauce
Singapore no still I openen right so so
Ikea is is is something that has all
that that cultural memory that all of us
love right so we have been approached by
by by um by uh British institutions
demential institution institutions in
the UK and also in America and this
going to a nice museum in 25 which we'll
share more next time yeah
yeah and the blind so your blinds
attached to it as well so you can
control like because that's when
dementia sufferers have a real um Panic
is when the light changes whether it's
Dawn or dusk right right so you could
little thing attached to it and it's all
super
affordable uh I'll just leave with this
uh quote you know I always believe like
a rich man is someone who can see Beauty
in everything right doesn't matter the
price right a powerful designer is
someone who can see possibilities and
everything
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you thank you King and hanai next
representing design of the Year state
courts Towers we have architect Colleen
U senior vice president architecture
from cpg Consultants private limited
colen has overseen and led many of its
landmark and award-winning project Pro s
in Singapore over the last 30 years
namely the gardens by the bay the
National Museum of Singapore Mandi
crematorium jurong Lake Gardens and the
upcoming joob baru Singapore rapid
transit system his ability to Envision
and Lead Mega and highly complex
projects from design Inception to
completion has helped cpg to Garner many
awards for its projects including being
recognized twice by the president's
design award let's welcome Colin to sh M
on State Court Towers Colin
[Applause]
[Music]
please thank you I'm very pleased to be
here this afternoon to share with you uh
the thoughts and the ideas behind the
making of state courts I thought perhaps
When I Was preparing this presentation I
would give it a title and the title will
be breaking new ground in Courthouse
design
uh just like Brian uh Capital spring uh
the making of state courts is indeed a
collaborative effort by many who have
contributed uh as a team uh special
mention to uh Syrian multiply uh our
partners uh and collaborators and
working hand inand with us in perfecting
the design of the state courts
unfortunately uh Chris is not able to be
here uh today at The Forum uh but it
send his
apologies so I thought I give a little
bit of background what really is indeed
uh the aspirations and indeed what
represents a state C Towers not many of
us will know uh what really constitutes
inside a CT building so in the very just
uh it is in fact an administration of
justice uh and is in fact an adherence
to the rule of law the building
functions but the architecture in it
conveys a very important uh character
that needs to be uh conveyed in the uh
fight final form that we have done and
there are aspects of transparency
fairness dignity and decorum but in the
brief also it mentions about the need
for this architecture to be Innovative
exciting and contribute positively to
the quality of Singapore's bu
environment also not like the Supreme
Court the state courts is indeed an a
building that has a higher degree of
interaction with the community and so
it's a building that should not result
in a fortress like building but rather
one that uh should be open but it also
at the same time should evoke a sense of
respect for the authority of the
court so a little bit about the
background on some of our court
buildings in Singapore uh the Supreme
Court from past to present but as you
can see mainly of it is a generally a
low R building
typology so it starts with the
vision sorry we have been actually
searching for the site uh good site for
the building uh and we have started
since the 90s the late 90s but
eventually the most important aspect
that determined the final location was
the vision of a Judiciary Hub here at
highblock Square where the state courts
eventually would be together integrated
with the new family justice courts which
is actually currently undergoing a major
an
forming a One-Stop integrated Judiciary
Hub and by this uh we know that
operations can be optimized uh they can
be shared amenities infrastructure and
resources so with this uh particular
site we have under overtaken actually is
an open uh surface car park and we knew
from the beginning that it was a going
to be a very very tight site and this
with the brief eventually led to a
messing that's going to be the the first
highrise courthouse in Singapore not
only is the first uh it's also going to
be the in fact today it is the tallest G
building here in Singapore but not only
that it has achieved to be one of the
three tallest couses in the world at 178
M
tall it also accommodates about 3 53
courtrooms and 54 hearing
Chambers so a bit about the design
approach uh three very important aspects
that we wanted to maintain one is
organizational Clarity two transparency
three the making of collective
spaces so in the first uh what we have
done here in in the design as opposed to
a singular building form uh the design
took its shape by creating two separate
Towers
distinctively clear in terms of its
organization with the front Tower occup
occupying the courts while the back
occupying mainly the support officers so
by this we have the front which is
called the cour Tower and the back the
office tower and these two towers are
linked together via Sky
Bridges as you can see from our studies
the rear Tower which is rather slander
is the office tower and we have the
slightly larger C Tower in the front
that's actually facing the current uh
former State Courts Building or we call
it the
Octagon again here we studied the scale
and the difference in height is compared
to the former State Cs and the new
that's going to come in form of the
tower again study model as you can see
from the photo of the model the rather
slender Tower at the
back the second design approach is one
of transparency here we see the open fac
S as a metaphor for the judicial system
here one that is fair one that is
transparent by this what the design has
done is that it's taken away the facade
that's very typical of a typical
highrise Tower here and removed it
revealing the contents within and from
by peeling away the facade what has
unveiled is that uh we start to see the
clarity of the floor plates which we now
Call It The Terraces and this on this
Terraces are where the CT rooms as you
can see those in the Square cubes or
boxes are placed
on again this is a study model that we
have done as you can see behind the open
frame structure are actually the CT
rooms which is the core function of the
C
Tower the third approach that we wanted
to do was to create a Collective space
and open space that created a place a
gathering space for uh Cod users this is
as opposed to what's more conventional
where we see the long Corridor picture
on the left feeding off to different
courtrooms this only creates further
anxiety and also disorientation to cour
users when they come for a court hearing
so instead we wanted to create an open
platform an open space that people could
gather and move around freely without
having that that anxi anxious feeling of
walking through a long Corridor to the
courtroom so in terms of form messing uh
as we mentioned earlier 2 versus one The
Two Towers enable it to not only have
independent function in terms of its
organization but also the towers were
read separately instead of a singular
large Tower and this help reduce the
visual impact of the design also The Two
Towers were designed to appear as if
they are slightly gently moving past one
the other never fully
aligned as we look at the tower itself I
think the important criterial as we
highlighted in the beginning was that a
CT complex had to present itself with a
certain pity and restrain and this is
actually carried through with the open
frame structure through the colonate
facade as you can see here the building
also took a very important octagonal
form as compared to curve forms and this
emphasized a classical order and
elegance a bit a modern articulation so
by this you can see a sense of formality
sense of order that befits a CT building
behind is also important it is the tower
the office tower at the rear so here the
office tower faces Singapore's CBD but
here it's expressed as a very tein and
elegant slap Tower but furthermore what
we have done is we have brought the G
the open frame structure also to the
rear of the building but here it
features in an expanding and Contracting
GD vertically if you can see the grid
contracts where the service CS are
located at the both ends and it expands
where light and Views are required in
the middle which are the officers
itself the modulation of the horizontal
GDs also bring the eye across the facade
and also Towards the Sky providing a
clean and absolute form with a sense of
a playful
rythm more importantly the tower itself
had to respect its two neighbors and by
the two neighbors one is a National
Monument which is the current Family
Justice Courts two is the former uh
State Courts Building which we call it
the octagon it's a conserved building so
these two buildings stood very near in
proximity to the new tower and at the
end of the day the tower had to relate
had to respect well of the this
buildings especially the octogen which
has a very very strong geometric
form uh furthermore what is important is
that if you can see the Octagon building
that side has with it strong geometry
forms those forms are actually the court
rooms itself so in a sense the old
octagon expressed the court rooms which
is its core function externally and the
new tower in itself had also
Incorporated in the same approach where
where now one can see with the unveiling
of the facade the actual core function
of the tower which are the courtrooms
itself so this is a way a very sensitive
approach that carried forth the same
approach from the oct octagon to the new
tower also in designing the building uh
especially a CAU building uh requires a
very tough very deep understanding of
the
complexities and programming and
culation primarily three major groups
which is the judges the persons in
custody and the public so the two
slander Towers while linked by the
bridges created this very dramatic void
space that brought in natural light in
the middle but more importantly it also
helped in terms of creating a controlled
circulation but more than just the floor
plate the planning of the C uh C spaces
are not just horizontal but vertical
nature so a Tara understanding uh is
needed in its planning and most
importantly the as mentioned earlier the
criteria to separate these three user
these three groups are very critical in
the planning of the whole
Tower so again the uh two towers are
linked by 39 Bridges while they function
as Bridges and circulation they also
form a structure element that provides
uh both Towers to function single L as
one we had to even carry a wind tunnel
test to validate that the deflections of
the tower particularly the office tower
are within human
Comfort most importantly the
relationship between the city is
something that we wanted to address to
to this public building and what's
important is that we wanted to bring the
two architectures one that is something
typical and one of the new modern
highrise together to create something
that is familiar and yet surprisingly
new to all and by this we created we
wanted to create a identity that's
distinct yet familiar and where the
courtroom boxes were eventually clad in
the preast pigmented preast concrete
panels that took the inspiration from
the roof colors and textures of the
terata roof tows that we see in
Chinatown these are some of the work
efforts behind the scene it's a lot of
Ingenuity here because it's not from the
textbook and a lot of tests and a lot of
experiments that we had to do to finally
come up with a product that we are very
very satisfied with so it's more Beyond
just more than just mere finishes
because this material has been applied
three-dimensionally across the
courtrooms to create a volumetric box
for the courtrooms and also these panels
function as physical enclosures to the
courtrooms behind without the need of a
secondary
wall so again the lobes are very
important as we frame and allow natural
light in but most importantly we are
also framing providing orientation to
the visitors with the former State CS
building behind as you can
see we wanted to create Collective
spaces as we mentioned earlier and this
is one of the efforts that we have done
that we wanted to create places of calm
and respite for court users before the
beginning of their legal proceedings and
by the sky Terraces this enabled people
to find this Precious Moment before the
proceedings
began so again uh large Greenery is
something that we wanted to bring into
even a Judiciary building and where the
sky Gardens on 12 of his Terraces are
fully
landscaped not for forgetting even the
rooftop of the podium is one that we can
create an
opportunity as I call it the Great
Divide between the two
towers uh lastly and a few more slides I
think this is an important uh link that
arrive the entrance canopy that links
The Two Towers from the old C building
and the new tower but more importantly
it's also a framing of the past which
you can see the monument behind which is
the Family Justice Court
again stepping in into the foer it is
something that uh brings a sense of
decorum for any visitor entering this
court building knowing that one has
enter into a different
space so I'll just quickly run through I
think the time is already done this is
part of some of the C plannings which I
think many of us will never get a chance
to see so I thought I give you the
privilege to see what a court room
really looks like okay so do have a look
at it uh this is indeed uh interior uh
nice to see through a photo but not
being there all right okay so again it's
a modern courtroom with a lot of it
features that we
have Mansions Court this is the largest
one it's a double volume
space and lastly in a night I think this
is important for public building that
also would have uh it's lighting as a as
a as a public building to be seen not
just appreciated in a day but but also
in the
night okay thank
you um I'm so happy to be back here to
know that this room actually is back in
business um after the covid because um
many thoughts many designs many
discourse has been shared here I think
this is um uh what we as architect
valued uh sharing our
uh thoughts with each
other and um every
design
um I and the team will start with
sketches like these and my two is
actually quite
simple um a normal
pener and a two-headed blue and R pener
I don't do computer drawings so when my
colle
um uh produce the drawing I would use my
pener to um to kind of like uh command
on the
drawings now what I'm showing here is
the initial sketches for um uh Singapore
Pavilion uh for Shanghai uh
um the concept was a a musical box we
wanted to share with people the talent
we have um the the cultural Talent the
subculture Talent like uh Stephanie sun
or JJ Lin or some
designers and so um the the initial
concept was around the
building um why because I thought I want
the message is we are not as Square as
you
think okay and this box actually uh um
is naturally challenge to show you my
folio over 30 40 years but we have
selected a few and important um they are
compact very compact form of uh
architectural
um uh uh discipline if you like and um
they allowed you
to understand the local climatic
condition the needs of the client as
well as testing our architecture form
and later on you can use it or use them
for other
projects so over the years we have been
designing uh we have the opportunity to
design quite a few houses and as you can
see because uh the um the clients the um
the needs are different the characters
are different so um the outcome of these
houses are also
different at this point I must say that
there is one book that influenced me a
lot that is the book by Mr liit Lyn the
Singapore
house and um I met kiplin in England um
in the '90s
and um we share our kind of like uh
thoughts about uh tropical
houses and of course I understand what
he was trying to uh tell us about the
traditional black and white houses how
wonderful they are but my role I thought
then is after understanding this
perhaps I will give them a new life I
will use the uh the modern kind of like
aesthetic uh to continue that um
tropical houses idea so you can see in
here there are some uh the Double roof
uh the the lightweight secondary roof
actually allow the ventilation of air
just like what we have of the big pit
roof and the ceiling with a space to
allow
ventilation now are Hing to one house
that we design and I'm very fond
of um this house belongs to Dr hang and
and uh it is a house that uh it shows
the the close bonding between her and
the particularly the younger son because
you see the son has been away for many
years
and he couldn't quite decide whether he
want to come home or not being a
investor uh Banker he he is very
successful and the mother probably
hoping to build this house
uh even a ouse or a accommodation for
him to his brief perhaps he would come
back more often so you see on the
right the um the house for the son is
more
open and for the mother uh which is the
house the main house is in um in a
U-shaped form is more
enclosed and but within the two houses
there is one
gesture uh they
share the mother house has got a
horizontal L-shaped form that is the um
um the marble wall which I explain to
you why and then the uh the sun will
have this ltis also in nail shape but
vertically jump over the roof and allow
natural ventilation again because he
like to uh invite friends over for
parties and all
that these picture um was intentional
because um I always remember there's one
painting in
uino called the ideal city and that
painting has got a building with a door
slightly a
jar and this house the main house has
the same quality because you then can
look into the house the inner side of
the mother that has got a court yard
with bonai with trees and is very warm
and and soft
inside and then um at the side the
two buildings they share similar
aesthetic okay and they they are both
looking onto the swimming pool which the
mother and the son share
then we realized along the way when we
were
designing um the mother of course is a
Ken a collector of Arts as well as wine
and what have
you but there is this
particular um sculpture or
artifacts she kept away in a store room
then we realized it was something that
she and the husband
pass away by the time we designed the
house collected when they went around
China giving lectures they are both very
successful uh doctors and of course uh
we decided to display them to display
them in a more intimate
environment on second floor and um is
the family room okay and I don't want to
overplay it
so we allow natural light sort of like
gradually uh lit up the
collection well the natural light
actually occur because of the L-shaped
War being pull out from the main wall of
the RC
structure and so um this is a pierce
Hill House talking about architecture
for the people
I think uh um it is rewarding uh when
client like this share with you they are
very personal sort of like uh details
and then we as architect we responded to
it
next Factory buildings usually are not
being emphasized or looked up
to however we have the
opportunity to design a very unique uh
brand of Singapore that is bre talk uh
group and when we started the BR talk
HQ um the chairman um George Craig as
well as
JTC wanted something quite different
from what we know the conventional type
of industrial
building and um the building is at a
junction busy very busy Junction of
daang and um oh I can see one of my
colleague who sitting who is sitting at
the back who look after this
building um and he will share with you
the experience we had um
now on the um on the right right is
Select building which we designed after
uh bread talk but slightly different
differently because select is famous for
uh uh food food C uh lunch uh takeaways
and um Chinese dium so uh we devis this
um dimsum basket like uh ceramic towels
if you like to uh cover up the um the
exhaust uh windows and all that and that
uh ceramic part is uh being was being
done in Taiwan by a camic
artist back to
uh um bread talk as well as um uh some
other buildings because of brt because
of the um uh the three in one meaning
the HQ the central kitchen and the
retail part all comes
together uh traditional uh Industrial
Area become Lively not only uh um the
neighbor uses the building to lunch or
dinner we notice that Singaporean would
drive all the way there to with the
family over the weekend so it actually
works now uh currently we are designing
a a similar type of building in shinen
and then the one below is in chjo which
is near lanin and um the owner also
collected uh sculpture so it Formed part
of the building the HQ building and
bring live to the uh the business park
there okay uh the
building this
building um was inspired
by the layer of cakes and bread that
bread talk actually
produce but the shifting of these
flaw has a intentional purpose um it
provide
shading of Flor the floor below and the
different volumes actually comes from
the needs within like certain uh Central
Kitchen they they need higher volumes or
storage area so with that we are able to
um compose the form if you like with uh
outside
Terraces uh to provide uh shading as
well as some uh
Greenery and
surprisingly it also introduce um air
pockets for better
ventilations
this are images of uh brat talk uh lower
floors um the concept is actually quite
simple it's not unlike um when you go to
a showroom of um BMW or Audi to test out
your um your cars so you come here you
sample the
delua that uh they would serve or you
look at the um the model of uh how they
operate for the foreigners the
investor they would say oh I like that I
will I will take that and I'll bring
back to um India or uh Dubai or England
um so it works for um breed
talk on the Upper Floor the uh the top
two floors
um
these spaces are mainly used for
administration um
logistic as well as um meetings of the
staff and
training however we do not want um the
sort of like conventional partitioning
of the spaces so um instead or we use uh
various sizes of
uh glass boxes as internal cour not
unlike what you see in uh traditional
houses and so the people can work next
to a greenhouse if you like a outdoor
greenhouse and they can also get the
natural light as well as when it's
raining they can feel the mood of the
weather and
this in a way is a partition is a
segregation between the two departments
or between
departments the next uh subject I like
to talk about is uh conservation work
that we our office has been
doing
[Music]
um although we have done quite a number
of uh conservation projects but each of
them
are rather different um due to the the
site condition as well as the historical
background and so the first one is the
sutan hotel now uh sutan Hotel uh um set
in Kong Glam which is a really I mean uh
important Cultural District of
Singapore not only that this is very
rare that uh two row of
houses became available that almost
like there actually about 10 of them
with uh one of them being the um um a
press building uh that was established
uh in the 199 in the '90s I mean uh
about 100 years
ago and so we um took over the task to
to um to combine them into a converted
them into a 64 room
hotel and more
importantly um there are common spaces
like the back alley as well as the
narrow corridors that the local people
are still using and uh we uh lcap them
and Revitalize them and give back to the
community the spaces as they
wanted and you can see it was quite run
down and you can also see uh the feature
of this um main building has got um
Malay feature uh tradition traditional
Western uh classical feature as well as
some Chinese feature so is truly
Multicultural selecting of suitable
material
colors um to match as well as landscape
the uh the back alley otherwise is a no
man
land next
ptrs um
btrs um as you know uh stop
functioning um since the train is no
longer running between us and
Malaysia
and so uh we took on the task not only
to restore the old building of the
station but we also
introduced soft Landscaping hard
Landscaping to allow the jogger or the
cyclist to enjoy the stretch of the
green
Corridor and um the lines you see on the
Landscaping um
was the idea taken from a photo taken by
a local
photographer uh Darren Soul he captured
the moment the train last left the
station but the photo was in these
strips of light because of the movement
of speed that the train went through and
so it become the uh the flooring
materials that uh we later on
uh
introduced um in the
project again just like uh just now uh
one of you mentioned uh we um have to
talk to the local people the
community and uh the user to collect the
view about uh what they actually want
for these uh space as well as the two
old buildings before we start
amenity like a washroom and all that was
also part of the
brief the third uh conservation
project uh took us about six years to
complete of course uh with um a covid in
between it actually prolonged it
but it it it was useful because it need
that sort of time for us to actually H
up skill and make sure it's done
properly the Gallup is unusual because
is the six uh Hector of land is a
combination of two different plot of
land um as you can see on the uh the
right hand side the more uh sort of like
tropical forest the more wall area was
the land uh which one uh belongs to the
sutan of joall and then um the land that
was uh sort of like nicely manicure with
the two houses on it belongs to um the
two houses of number five and number
seven we then have to
um include or create additional
buildings such as uh um phys
reception a children playground a cafe
and a restaurant among uh other other uh
things uh as you can see uh on the plan
uh we actually uh uh allow the um the
passage for the visitor to be in between
the two plots of land so is turning and
winding towards the two houses which
then one of them become gallery of
botony Science and another one a gallery
for boton's
art and um we were very uh careful when
we placed the new building like the uh
Visitor Center as well as the the new
restaurant building because there are
hierachy to be
observed and this building is important
because we realize that bit well he
refer a lot to not only English
architecture like uh the building by
Philip web um the red house but also the
English landscape movement so we have to
continue that language not only uh when
we are laying down the the path and the
um uh the walkway but also when we
create this uh restaurant building
we actually plac the building at a the
slope of a hill so that it's slightly
lower than house number seven the
inventory however we took the hinge from
him because there was a 45 degree cut in
inside the building although is
perfectly sort of like
symmetrical but he did this gesture to
introduce the service area towards the
back going towards the back and so we
took the 45
Dee uh uh line externally and place the
restaurant
there oh I only three minutes to go I'll
try the uh the new
building uh did not mimic uh house
number seven instead we decided we are
going to to have
uh uh
360° uh glass building um and the
curvature actually uh was inspired by um
local flower like a a piece of
orid these are external um view of
Gallup and you can see that uh not only
the uh the building but the Landscaping
continue that English landscape movement
and one thing I want to um sort of like
highlight is that throughout the whole
site next time when you go there please
pay attention to the sell that is next
to the uh walkway because these collect
rain
water and then uh we um recycle the
water to uh irrigate the plant
within the
garden um some of the internal View and
um these um some of the the the old uh
elements like the Randle window the uh
the save are some of some of the
important elements we have to um Salvage
and uh we have to find a maker to
replace them uh when uh when we realize
some of them are
missing and finally um the client to us
perhaps um there is a need for a
connection between the older uh botanic
garden and the new one and so finally we
added this foot bridge to connect the
two now
now um I want to talk about
um another type of buildings we do
that's
bookshops we've been very fortunate
since the '
90s uh uh the appreciation of good
design the appreciation of uh good
architecture and more importantly for
myself through this writing I question
question what actually make a good
design or what make a good City
takes and sometimes you don't realize
until you complete the writing then it
Don you oh is
that uh that unexpectedly emerge so
writing is very much part of my thinking
process
the last few weeks or a couple weeks
since um uh knowing that I got this
award I've been asked many time well a
bit like a film director winning the
Oscar and then they ask you so what's
next well I've chosen to show you one
project that we are doing and this
project is in east of turkey is in Van
and this town is a historical town it
was the capital for Armenian
people and it has got a beautiful Lake
and is surrounded with
mountains the clim was very lucky
because he own uh
50,000 square meter of land that is
facing the lake and he's a hotelier so
this is his hometown he want us to
design a b Banquet Hall that can hold
Wedding Banquet
exhibition or outdoor
concerts and a hotel towards the back
where the uh Hill slope is and in
between by the way there is a wonderful
Orchard that's been ongoing for I don't
know hundreds of years because uh the
the orchard was past now generation to
generation so this is a hall that we are
building now uh you can see the lobby
building the washroom and the night
night
view this is work in
progress okay after talking about the
future I like to bring you back to the
past in
1985 James
Sterling um has written a brief for
young designer for rbaa
students uh is to design a gallery for
David hotney the British uh artist and
Anthony
Caro I was then already uh working in I
just graduated from the AA and I started
working at Arab Associates but I
participated uh the
competition and recently I went back to
our London
Studio I haven't looked at these
drawings for a long time but because I
know I'm going to give this talk so I
actually opened up the old folios and
these are all kind of like handr
drawings before the auto had oh well
maybe or to get restarted I I didn't
know but it was sort of like uh roin pen
on tracing kind of
drawings now the uh the concept is very
simple the concept was as you know taken
from the painting by uh David hotney and
the the bodies the two bodies of the
building actually rotate kind of like
they relate to each other other because
of different height of the floor plate
so as you are enjoying the the paintings
the
artwork sometime you're
inside sometime you're outside because
the ram will take you in and out um and
so um this is the um the concept for
that
competition and what I want to say is
that at that time I was
very enthusiastic
about uh Renaissance architecture
particularly uh
Shinu um the uh neoc classical um
architect from
Berlin and the perspective perhaps uh is
a bit Fain because it was done in just
you know uh simple
rendering um was inspired by one of the
perspective by shinku
he look from the inner side of a
building which is under Shadow then look
out to outer space and look onto another
building not unlike if you go to uh
Gallop you stand along the corridor of
The
Archers at abara and look towards
uh house number seven you have the same
caros Guru
effect that I was talking
about I want to thank uh PDA for giving
me this prestigious prestigious award
I'm really honored and most of all
giving me a
opportunity
to look into my own old fols which are
there with that I thank
you thank you KY may I invite the
speakers including Dr Joshua karov from
Team heck care to join keny at the seats
in front we will now move on to the Q&A
session moderating this
session
moderating this session is architect
kudin saharo Kai graduated from the
National University of Singapore with a
masters of architecture degree and was
awarded the Lian gold medal for being
the top graduate in 1999 he established
kite Studio architecture in 2010 to
provide architectural services that seek
an invigorating approach to design and
heighten spatial experience in 201 17
Kai was selected as one of the promising
Architects under the age of 45 as part
of ur's 20 under 45 initiative currently
he sits on the Singapore Board of
Architects and serves as a board member
for the Malay Heritage Foundation
besides being a familiar phase in the
media and having hosted many television
programs for both local and Regional
networks Kai is also an illustrator for
books we will now take questions from
the floor you may also scan the QR code
shown on the screen to meet to your
questions all right thank you very much
for that generous introduction thank you
um speakers and uh Award winners it has
indeed been a delight for us to hear
your stories and narratives how designs
are conceived whether or not from layers
of cake or Kaya toast or even from
frustration uh in case of uh uh King's
works right and and I think if there
there's two important common threats
that I could take away from the
presentations the fact that not only
that the designs are very people Centric
but the designs are able to cross into
the threshold of innovation and
invention now that's something that's
really hard because you can design a
window in many
ways this you can design something
differently in many ways
but the threshold is to design it
meaningfully and I think for that all of
your Works have proven that that that
going to the threshold pushing the
boundaries of innovation and and
well-deserved witness to to all of you
so so my first question is possibly a
very generic question how do you as a
designer right um what tools or design
Consciousness is needed for designers to
to kind of get to the threshold of
innovation and
invention anyone uh perhaps uh Ki would
you like to
begin well that's almost a question
that's all we ask uh from the
students um well I always answer that
are two main factors to start with one
is the external Factor you have to look
at the side we look at the um the
condition of the
surrounding then there is the um
internal um factor which is the brief be
it a house be it a HQ be a hotel the
client will have special
needs then uh the third factor is up to
you how you interpret how you understand
perhaps The Cult cultural s of
things um so um a design that is um
resolved by us will be different from uh
someone else because of the personality
because of the
experiences I think that's good to start
with right okay
yeah mean this just a lay on I mean I
totally agree with what um K said um
just to get a bit bit of perspective I
so so my my training was in Netherlands
in in einhoven and it's you know Dutch
style um and what I mean it's utterly
honest so so we were master's class of
30 and we graduated in 15 right and at
every stage you ask us so what does
design mean to you are you sure you want
to be a designer are you sure like like
if not then leave and many people left
right so so I think I think that is
something that it's a conviction right
it's a conviction to what we do we can
do tons of stuff in life so why do
design why do architecture why do
whatever you're doing right so I think I
think during the Master's course we were
confronted with that and I think you
know in the work that we've done you can
see that we we truly own what we are
doing or or or we really want to find
that super nice uh uh it spends a lot of
time you know to find that super nce you
know relationships or specs of projects
to really really apply your talents and
your passions to something that you
believe in at the same time would impact
people right because sometimes you can
get over ego and then like oh no so
actually there's a lot of relinquishment
of of of ego as well uh um I I think
when you truly want to impact in in
projects so conviction I think I would
say is a huge part of it right Joshua
would you like to say
something I mean I think personally from
from our kids just from the I'll just
speak to the experience of this the Hat
Care Project um for us I think it really
had to do with looking back again at the
person of the user and starting to in
really give up certain assumptions we
had about who that person was I think
like many people who go to design school
there's this idea that you always carry
of the typical user right the idea of
inclusive design or accessible design is
a kind of favor we do to people who are
disabled right we make special
accommodations for people who are are
not able-bodied or whatever and it was
really
renouncing that idea I think that got us
to a place of actual kind of innovation
in this particular project was of um
getting to rethink who our user was
their daily experience how they just uh
experience Simple Spaces simple kind of
architectural configurations simple kind
of visual configurations language color
these kinds of aspects um and to see
them menu in order to then have to
design them again have to design them to
a different user who is not a kind of
fictional or mythical typical user and
what we found very compelling about that
is when we would show people some of the
designs that we tweak they' say oh that
might be useful because you you know I'm
a normal person but I have a lot of
trouble with this or I get visually
confused when there are too many colors
in my environment or I I can't stand big
changes in light or or kind of harsh
Silhouettes and we realize that actually
a lot of um room still exists when we
think very carefully about the US and
about how they actually experience space
as opposed to a kind of shorthand that
we often use um you know for who they
are and how we should design for
them yeah I got take the mic from you um
I think it's it's a very important
question and I think the the common
threat of what people are saying so far
I really agree with that you you have to
ask the the big questions in the the
beginning to think more about outcomes
necessarily than the the constraints and
one thing we always try to ask ourselves
is why does architecture have to look
like architecture because sometimes if
you if you take the the different
ingredients and understand how they need
to perform individually it allows you to
to think about how they can come
together in a way that that is
unexpected that has that has never been
seen before and and and and and I think
I I was actually sitting there watching
the the presentation very very inspired
by
the the um all of the the content around
around hack care and I think
especially the the kind of hacking of
elements so that they have a
performative function but they don't
necessarily look like something that was
designed in a way that it was to meet
accessibility requ
requirements and and and I think it's
that kind of thinking about you know why
why shouldn't everyone have access to
the same level of design to the same
experience that can lead you down a
different path of of getting there so
it's not about Aesthetics but it's about
it's about really about understanding
kind of you know about in this case you
know Equity of of access Equity of of
experience to to different
people the the important question is is
also about how then do you push it so
that it has your personality it has that
additional factors that you think it is
needed in the design and sometimes you
have authorities you have uh clients and
all these problems that crop up and and
just just dishearten you it makes you
you know just just fed up and with
things and just want to throw away your
your road tring tools and or to C um
what do you think as designers we need
uh what on it's it more particularly the
software that we need in ourselves so so
that we are a bit more resilient and and
how do you tackle these problems I'm
sure building Capital spring uh spring
you have tons of authorities
requirements that needed to be resolved
right for fssd and all that how do you
have that
level-headedness that you can plow
through them properly and come up with a
fantastic uh product at the end of the
day
it's funny I gave a talk last week at SD
and the the first question at at the end
was how do you how do you deal with
clients it was kind of like this
question of um it wasn't um maybe that
outright but but how do you deal with
people who crush your dreams when you're
a young architect starting out and and I
think what we've we've found is that
it's it's so important for Architects to
be to be
proactive and and engaging with things
and not being reactive to to constraints
that are imposed on you and I think
capitus spring is a great case in in
point where what we it was a design
competition uh that we did what we
submitted in the design competition
looked quite different in very many ways
from what uh resulted in in the end and
if you look at the the area called the
green Oasis in the middle I think is is
a great example of that where we won the
competition we working on it with the
client we brought it to the UR the first
thing they said is those plants are all
going to die I am not going to allow you
to build this unless you can prove to me
that that you can do something that is
um legitimately green we don't want to
just put plants in a in a sky ter it's
not
greenwashing um and that set about a
whole um process for us where we really
had to understand what plants need to
survive what what what is the spectrum
of light they needed to survive what
does that mean in terms of the design of
the the space and it's really the result
of taking all of those constraints in a
very positive way and imagining how that
could create something new for us um so
so there is a you know architecture
design is is inherently um a labor of
love that is about deeply embedded
optimism in in in the world being able
to be a better place and and I think
that really needs to be a core value
that is held on to
tightly maybe answer yes both
questions okay I think uh I'm brought to
mind reminded of a very unique project
uh that was quite privileged to do uh if
you seen in the ear TV was the mandai
crematorium I think this is actually a a
building yes uh we have the contacts we
have the uh brief but I think one thing
that uh we had to put ourselves into is
to into the emotions that the Nicks of
King were EXP experience when you go
through the ferary process uh much alike
I think similarly for all buildings as
designers we need to really indulge
ourself into the emotions the feelings
what the occupants go through what do we
desire to help them with I think as
designers we can help them one step two
steps I think we have done our job well
uh and I think that's where I'm reminded
uh it's a difficult project uh even and
question number two the clients didn't
know how to to understand the nature of
the project so together with them we
literally had to experience this whole
journey you may just take 45 minutes
through that whole process but from one
space to the other was indeed a very
different experience from the paring of
your loved one to watching of the loved
one being pushed into the into the
cremators it's a very very tough moment
so we had to literally debate we
literally had debates among ourselves
with the clients to try to understand
and be BR external parties uh to try to
give a a holistic view what exactly do
the Mi of King go through during this
very very tough moment so that that in a
sense uh in my personal experience has
helped me to take myself to a different
level from Project to project try to
immerse one into the understanding of
the nature of the project the emotions
the feelings and then as a designer as a
Creator what can we do to help Elevate
the situation by just one step or two
steps better and it will mean a lot to
them it will mean a lot to the occupants
of the building so this is something
that I I just wanted to share it's a
memory of the past but I thought it's a
very yeah Shing you want to say
something yeah I just wanted to Echo a
bit what Brian was saying about
designers I mean talking about
Architects but I think anybody who is a
creative um is really an eternal
optimist um believing in the power of
design to do things that the lack of
design would not be able to accomplish
um but also in addition to that is
really having something to say I mean I
found it quite funny kany came in and
said he loves being back here because we
all want to talk about stuff we all have
things to say and I would say that's
really the key I mean obviously the
magic of design is something else right
there's a bit of alchemy there's a bit
of science a bit of art a bit of magic
um of course there are methods to
designing but there's always a little
bit of magic right um but the key thing
before that is first just seeing
things precisely so I think all of us
and you know design school teaches you
this is to
identify something in the world that
doesn't sit right like the something
that isn't quite right whether it's just
with a site whether it's you know a
problem of you know accessibility or
whatever at any scale um and then to be
able to very accurately describe why you
think that's a problem with that and to
kind of describe that and share that
with other people and then once that
vision is very clear it it gives you the
the kind of resilience you know at least
it's something to fall back on a really
core belief to fall back on that helps
you despite all of that uh you know
clients throwing changes at you in in
the in in that same line of thought do
you think that design needs to come from
a need or a problem must design always
be about problem solving can it be
something else above and beyond that I
think opportunity it doesn't have to be
a problem but it's something you know
it's a place where you can change
something for the better right so it can
be a small problem can be a massive
problem um or could just be a place for
opportunity something to change for the
better I think um a friend you know who
is um the design curator M plus Museum
Hong Kong surely maybe some of you know
her she said that design is a modulator
of of reality
right design modul is reality right and
and and and and how the design that we
have reflects the beliefs of the day the
Technologies of the day so and so forth
right so to answer your question it's
it's really like do we need more chairs
do we need more buildings right of
course we do because there are new
problems new context new framings new
demands on society new sustainability
issues right so so I think by by default
there be these things that Bubble Up and
people who find oh I find this
interesting let's let's let's go for
that you know you know you know but
maybe I just rewind back a bit about
about the the the the like how to be a
how
to how to handle clients right I think
that's that's always a very relevant
project because creators just want to
keep giving is our nature to give or
budget like that huh okay I'll still
give you know and that's that's bad
right and that's bad because we just so
bring with stuff just so much to give
right um so so it's I think it's just to
do such concise and remarkable work that
you attract the clients that you want
right and to say no no is powerful you
know and to like who who deserves to
work with me who who deserves my work
right and then therefore oh then there's
a budget for it so because budget is
also a commitment to what we're trying
to achieve together right so so it's
that self- resect and and like demanding
of of of that you know and and how do
you get how you do remarkable work is is
by I always believe that if you want to
do excellent design you must be an
excellent person and how you become an
excellent person expose yourself you
know always be kind be open know your
food know your drinks know your wine
know your culture what is $2 worth here
what's to Los worth there what's 2,000
oh that's nice what's what's what's 20
cents you can as I said before you can
find beauty in all levels I mean it's
it's like wow you can paint with all the
Cod of reality that that you want you
know and this be architecture or design
because it's just complicated problems
and everyone needs to come together yeah
can I can I turn the table around a bit
um we always talk about we as designer
and what we how we solve problems but
actually we spent one year two years
three years on a
project but the client actually leave in
the project for the following 10 15 20
years um more and more as a
designer I enjoy much more not seeing my
design being built but actually seeing
my design being enjoyed by the the
clients the user like for instance uh
Gallup every time uh when we went to
Gallup you'll see group of people
enjoying the um the lawn sitting there
picnicking or people taking photos
wedding photos um whether you approve of
the addresses doesn't matter but they
really have a good time so uh I think um
these days I listen more to clients and
um um and really find out um what deep
down inside they want and these days I
hope my
architecture can be less or more
understated and less obvious and less to
your face because it got to blend into
the environment it got to share with
other buildings next to it so you are
not that important actually you know you
are just contributing one
bit in that environment this is how I
see it now having said that I think uh
I've been lucky I don't know um uh the
the authorities the the government
agency uh they have been kind to me I
mean I listen to them as well and uh and
when we kind of like have a problem like
for instance um you need to resolve the
uh Universal Design issue for a old
building like Gallup um you cannot just
smack a disabled lift next to uh 120
year old building so by conversing what
are the possibilities and all
that um uh using a ram which is part of
the landscape element
anyway came about and mates it very well
so the the the um the solution sometimes
you'll be surprised it actually comes
from
um yeah the uh the um the authority you
know yeah so I won't see them as
confrontational I see them as someone
also wanting our environment to be
better I I I totally agree with that
statement because sometimes the
regulations that we have we as
Architects right we have Tendencies to
just read them face value without
understanding why they are there and and
and once we take that level to fully
understand where the guidelines are
coming from and then if you think that
the guidelines need to be changed have
that discourse and try to you know weave
your way throughout around it so that uh
design need not be stifled by a certain
guideline and in fact there's some
Authority guidelines that the
authorities Listen to I must say I mean
um programs like Lush right and because
of lush you see beautiful Rooftop
terrores in cap spring and even in state
courts right and and and what else do
you think
can be done by organizations by
authorities to support these people
Centric efforts in our work
anyway
no what else can be done yes oh I think
like what keny said that
um to seek to understand I think it's
important uh as we bring forth of a
purpose in what we are doing uh whether
it's the statutary board whether it's
the authorities I think we all together
as one uh today there's no uh individual
who can say that I can just do it all by
myself it's a collaborative effort a
large team so I think what is needed is
a a very strong purpose and I think
together with the authorities as well uh
of course we appeal that authorities
together will try to seek to understand
first uh what why we are doing what we
are doing uh and if it does need to
deviate slightly I think this is where
uh there has to be a room for
understanding Mo adjustment uh I'm not
saying one side or the other both sides
and I think that's where uh we have seen
we have seen uh before how the
authorities of so have come to work
alongside the architects in overcoming
uh certain obstacles and certain
compliances but in order to achieve a
greater Vision a greater purpose so we
have seen that I think this is the the
spirit that we want to encourage uh
going forward in the future that I think
as a nation we want to work together for
a greater purpose all of us
together um actually I was just I was
handed the mic because there was there
was great confidence I could contribute
something to this conversation but but I
but I do have to say that since
um
um we started working in in Singapore
about eight years ago now I I I think
there has really been a focus on more
performative outcomes rather than
prescriptive and and I think that's
something that's very important because
at the end of the day it's about um
setting in focus a vision and how you
achieve that and the process or the
journey in you know in which you get
there doesn't necessarily need to be
overprescribed and and and I think that
kind of openness
to to to being more process oriented is
is something that I've noticed in the
the the last eight years or so okay and
which which I think is something that is
is very important to um to design I mean
but but I would also say
that constraints in a way are the the
mother of invention and I think
the the worst projects we work on are
the ones where people clients
authorities tell us it's an open field
do whatever you want you know you you
need something to you need something to
respond to you need something to
contribute you need some you need in a
way a problem to solve and and I think
the word Elevate was used earlier in a
way that that kind of allows
architecture to to elevate the
experience of the community to
contribute something positive right so
in in that respect
right are there any instances where the
design elements of Capal spring could
not be executed because of a certain
guidelines or certain uh constraints
that you have or otherwise it would be
uh even more fantastic for example right
are there any instances that you faced
in in the
project um I think we attempted to
convince the client that they should uh
that they should in turn attempt to
convince the UR to to allow us more
height so that it could be the tallest
building in
Singapore but but but that's that's a
little bit um you know
factious um I I I really I I really
don't think so because I think
the I think I think there was a very
well defined sense
of of what could be done on the site
when we came in and what we attempted to
do in in a way was um was
simply to to be midwives almost to the
coming into existence of of something
taking these different ingredients and
trying to combine them in a way that
allowed us to create something new I
think if anything if I go back to the
example of the the green Oasis in the in
the middle of the the kind kind of
constraints opposed by the imposed by
the authorities their expectations for
example allowed us to create new
processes to design something that we
would not have done on our own and and I
think that's where I go back to the this
idea that I think as Architects it's
important to be positive and proactive
and to take these things and imagine how
it could allow you to create something
new and and unseen rather than as
something that necessarily kills your
dreams right I think uh um I I don't
think it needs to be t is building the
world to stand out I think the building
is as elegant as it is today um okay I'm
going to take questions from
SLO very interesting questions by the
audience today um
right how do you know when to stop as
Architects or designers for that matter
we enjoy refining how do you how do you
manage timelines particularly in the
context of relatively short design faces
anyone
tough
question a straightforward question when
a month man hours and budget runs out
right I mean I mean that's that's a
practical question right um but you know
always know that in your hearts of
hearts that yeah this could go further
if you had a bit more time bit more
budget if they could capture what we're
trying to say um yeah but is that the
answer you're looking for uh I don't
know whoever is asking this question not
it's a it's a real it's a real problem
it is knowing knowing when to stop but I
I think it's something where you have a
you have a different perspective on it I
think like you know 15 20 years after
practice and experience is something
that matters a
lot yeah it's interesting because we're
speaking from a different time scale I'm
speaking from like month's time scale
you guys are speaking from a years time
scale right because I'll get industry
design and we do things like uh like
Windows for for air and oh every season
you know kind kind of thing um so I
always put in my email like yeah if I
guess we can't do it this time maybe
next time with more budget we can do it
okay okay okay and then Sometimes they
come back some they don't yeah I
actually quite like time limit because
uh I think um designer tends to
overdesign and um one one of the um
important factor or uh things that you I
would teach my students is that don't
put in too many ideas in one design and
learn to edit it's very much right
writing you know so um to have a time
limit is actually quite good second
thing is that I won't dwell on a design
uh like 24 hours I will go swimming I
will go and watch a film I will but then
it goes back to you remember uh
um Alexander language uh sleeping on it
that means allow your brain
to uh the subconscious to actually do
the design then uh when you put aside
the design you already thought through
everything but you going and do
something else the answer will emerge
somehow and when you catch it and that's
it that is the one and um not you know
constantly questioning yourself so time
limit can works sometimes so take a walk
go swimming do what you like and come
back to drawing board joging yeah and
jogging yeah and and time sheets guys I
think when your bosses ask you to fill
up your time sheets please do so
religiously so that we
know right sh Shing and I actually used
to play a game where we'd go to an
architecture project and we' try and
spot the moment in the design when the
design should have gone home to bed it's
almost every project you can look and
say Ah that's when they should have just
put their pencil down and went to see
their wife or their kids you know right
and I hope you didn't pass one of my
projects okay um now um next question I
I guess this is more pertaining to he
care for heare do you have any stories
of people who have been impacted by the
publication locally or globally
um I mean not personally yes I mean it's
it's very interesting um that a lot of
friends even that I thought I knew
well I didn't know that they had a
family member with dementia um but after
it came out like it just opened all of
these conversations and they said I need
that I need that book um so so yes I
mean in in that respect um but in terms
of the hacks actually helping people um
that's something that when it came out
in 2020 lean Foundation really tracked
um they they had a few kind of live
hackathons they had callers um you know
viewers kind of call in and talk about
how this um you know how how the
publication impacted them um you know
the kinds of things that they did
whether it was helpful what they would
have changed Etc and they actually had
some you know these Instagram influences
like go to different places and kind of
work through hacks with them so that was
really
really amazing to us um yeah and I mean
I always tell this I I hope maybe nobody
in the audience has read the interview
in the PDA book because something I I
mentioned there but um we love how the
book yes it's meant for people with
dementia but it's really a kind of call
for a certain flexibility of thinking of
kind of constantly hacking SL designing
their way in life um through through
issues right that you can use that kind
of design thinking to kind of take
yourself through certain issues um and
one of the people who kind of wrote into
lean Foundation to us for the book was
somebody who ran a home for dogs with u
mobility issues and he really you know
he said this book is really going to
help him to
think how to change that environment for
those dogs so I mean it's a completely
different problem but again like it gave
us a feeling that it was about uh it was
successful in communicating a way of
thinking and approach yeah interesting
so you going to come up with a head care
for dogs or animals or something yes yes
huge
Market a huge Mark huge Mar now what's
what's also interesting that I caught
from your your your talk uh uh H was how
you decided your team decided to think
globally and hence write on this very
famous brand of furniture um and and
that's one thing I find that as a
designer sometimes we we tend to
internalize and just think locally that
that that aspect of of think Thinking
Beyond Regional globally is something
that maybe local designers need to have
uh and and and what how do you think
as a fraternity of designers we can
bring that Singapore brand at a global
to to the global
stage wow it sounds like some Ambassador
thing so let me tell you are ambassadors
yeah so so I think you know like it's
the ho question right what Singapore
design what Singapore brand right and
and and I I think that is not as
relevant as impactful design you know so
so how how how we see it is like because
in this this infocom scape these days
where everyone's attention is spliced to
the
nanometers right like how do you spread
an idea right it's like Inception right
like the idea is the thing right if if
someone has an idea and it goes on to
become good things or bad things you
know like like will affect millions of
people so so I think it's about how you
give exposure to your ideas right so
it's not so much about the format
anymore not so much of an archetype
anymore right so so we use Ikea because
it's a well-known brand right we use
hacking because it gives agency back to
the to the people right and and and I
mean for for for my practice at least we
made sure that the photography was is as
important as the product itself because
the photography is going to travel more
than the actual chair that we design or
you know so so when like we we like it
would appear in like magazines around
the world people we expose oh what's
that about and then they start to ask
and they go down the own rabbit holes
and try to find it so we have to make
sure that our content is Instagram aable
Tik talkable so and so forth while not
cheapening anything but with in respect
of that this is the information
infrastructure that we can exploit yeah
I think also we we are luckily in a
moment now with a certain level of
globalization of culture where it's not
just say Asian Nations that are forced
to accept kind of Western culture as a
kind of neutral um influence you know I
think nowadays with the kind of the
global the Mania for Korean culture the
kind of globalization of Japanese
culture in a way when we were doing this
book we always felt that it was
something that could be um full of
Singaporean identifiers but still work
globally uh at this point we didn't we
didn't feel like we needed to really
compromise anything I think even the
title The pun and the title is not going
to make any sense to an American it
doesn't matter if they stick with it
they'll figure it out if they read
enough about it they'll figure it out um
we Ed for the layouts were typically hdb
floor plates because we felt that that
you know if we needed to start with
anything as a kind of a neutral kind of
most impactful condition to work with we
should start at home but the idea then
is that you know hopefully there's
enough in the project enough in the uh
say this the sadly kind of global um
sharing of the dementia care experience
and its difficulties and its daily
struggles that hopefully it would still
kind of resonate just due to the nature
of the kind of problems we were trying
to address and then the medium we were
using to address
it k
um I I find the idea of exporting
Singapore designers
scary um because uh wherever we go
to um you you have seen the number of
kinas we have uh done and then uh we
even Venture into sort of like rare T of
turkey I tell you they have much more
profound kind of like culture or uh the
way of living
that we have to learn from and so um the
uh the identity of a
Singaporean architect or Singapore
architect is is very much secondary to
me because um I then will um see or
learn from them um unfortunately Turkish
language is so difficult not like uh
Italian or you know uh Japanese that we
can uh somehow comprehend one or two
sentences uh but is at the same time
fascinating so perhaps it's the other
way around I like to say you as a
Singaporean you go out please you learn
the way of life they already established
over hundreds of years the the piece of
land there that has been you know sort
of like going through so many
centuries China is a the same Taiwan is
the same Japan is the same so um I think
um we then um learn from them and then
to sort of like um take part of them
become part of us when we are
designing and so we accumulate all these
experiences perhaps when we bring home
you'll be our identity is the other way
around just like the sutan hotel you
look at the facade it's got a bit of
Malay a bit of Western classical order a
bit of Chinese Motif so Singaporean are
I'm I'm I'm so glad that we are we are
still young culturally so we are not
uptight in imposing what we have so
perhaps that is my Approach well there's
a saying that goes that culture should
never be
territorial in fact it should be
something that
is share with one another and I and I
guess that it's all about going to a
place honoring and respecting the place
and then interpreting if your own design
senses I suppose I suppose there's a
change and we hardly talk about design
movement today like uh International
Star when we were student we were C uh
that is the kind of like International
Star but these days you know who cares
uh you don't drop a International Star
Building to a remote uh town in turkey
or China because they don't need that in
fact uh there there have been samples of
uh repeating uh um formula if you like
commercial buildings and and what what
is the outcome they become very sad
because it couldn't merge with the local
culture you want to say something um
yeah I think there is there is one thing
for me where I think Singapore and the
the kind of experience here has a is a
very important relevance outside of
Singapore globally and that's in the the
area especially of climate resiliency
because I think Singapore has over the
decades learned how to deal with issues
of torrential rain of flooding of um of
very high temperatures in a in a way
that other parts of the world are just
coming to to grips with if you go to
Europe this summer you know temperatures
35 40 degrees are not unheard of even
you know today right now issues of of of
flooding and changing climate and and I
think there's a certain kind of
pragmatic attitude in how the
urbanism and and solutions are developed
in Singapore that is very to me you know
as someone living in in copen and has
been there for a long time now it's very
uniquely Singaporean where I think there
is an Avenue to be plugged into a very
Global conversation about what the the
future of climate resiliency of
infrastructure of urbanism looks like
okay I I suppose uh at this moment I
will just open uh the the discussion to
the floor and audience maybe yeah
uh CK
yeah
thank you to ur and all the speakers um
uh I have a question relating to some of
the projects relating uh you know that
has uh an old building in its context so
you have the Market Street uh car park
which was historic and of course the
whole site was uh torn down and rebuilt
uh but you also have the uh state courts
uh with a new bill uh right next to it
and of course this is not uh new right
you have the if you go down ACH road you
can see tanin Tuan building uh with a
Manion and then Sunday you have this
this very tall building uh going up uh
you have sadly Kate Cinema you know uh
Frank Brewer which was sort of taken
down and then this horrible building
that that went up uh so there is uh so
I'd like to ask uh uh uh call in this
question because I think uh and the
answer should actually really be given
by both uh calling n Ur because you know
as a typology right uh what is the
relationship and how do we uh relate to
these buildings do we just do a sort of
a gesture by just making a connection uh
to it and uh you know uh what what are
the things that we need to do because I
I'm also not seeing this in Singapore
I'm seeing this in Pang I'm seeing that
you know uh in a lot of the conservation
projects where you need to build more
the solution always is to give the uh
developers or the the client more land
and then you can build a toll buing up I
think I I think this process needs to be
taught through and moderated and also I
think uh what do you do with the old
building because like even in his uh
presentation Colin calls it the Octagon
where nobody calls it the Octagon right
so even the name is subverted uh in the
process we don't call it the Old State
cours or anything so I think this is
something that is is worth doing and and
to go back to uh claims there's a very
interesting story about the old state
courts uh which is that the PW team
that's proposed uh the scheme for it was
rejected by ew Baka because it was like
eight stories and he didn't want that to
to be there and so so he called upon his
friend from Cambridge or Victor Chu from
kulan aritex to have this what Colin
calls the the Octagon on on the side so
there is a very strange claim for it to
be the to building when you know the old
building actually wanted it to be
merging together with the landscape so I
do think this is a something that I want
to throw out uh because increasingly I
think we have to deal with the uh old
buildings but we also have to deal with
them uh sensibly and making just
gestures about you know oh the old
courts can be seen and you know and all
that I think it's it's it's just form
right and it's it's not it's not helping
us for very much thanks thank you so is
is that meant to be a comment or
all right okay do you want to respond to
that comment okay yeah sure yeah um
maybe I'll give us a broad generic on
conservation um
again okay uh maybe for my experience so
I think in one as we approach uh yes
there's going to be more and more of
buildings that we going to keep we going
to preserve uh and as as approach I
think uh conservation we know that we
need to fully understand the nature of
the original building what is the spirit
of the building uh what is the history
of the building the meaning of the old
building and see how we can uh
extrapolate from there and as we develop
the new I think we cannot deny that it
will be the new and the new likely going
forward is going to be much more massive
uh and that's where we have to pull
certain tracks across and how we can
understand the old and see whether the
new can correspond the old
in uh perhaps a poetic manner in a
sensitive manner a respectful manner so
again uh pulling it back to the okay I
just use the word octagon for Isa uh the
geometry of the Octagon is very very
strong it's a very prominent building uh
in fact it is a very interesting
building I think as we study the
building Interiors uh it's really a very
unique piece of work uh but when we do
something next to it uh once we have a
monument even next to it uh then the
question comes how do you treat how do
we detail what what is the initial
messing in the form of the new tower
that's going to take place so I think in
the state courts uh this is where as we
keep looking over and over and again I
think the towers in a way it's an
appropriate choice in its form uh in it
details it's not that it's secondary by
all means but I think it's sensitive
that it is respectful and it forms an in
I call the word backdrop backdrop
because it it doesn't stand out to
compete with the monument it doesn't
stand to compete with the octogen if he
had done that I think it would been
chaos tribling would been chaos so I
think that's where the design has very
sensitively in a very controlled manner
in a very ordered manner uh detailed the
form the octagonal form sorry of the
building and therefore counterbalances
the two buildings that's very very
strong and dominer so that in the whole
Collective whole the tree can stand
together as one in a very sensitive
poetic manner yeah so I think that's
where we have done it for State Court
thank you Colin uh we don't have any
more time for further questions so I
would like to end by asking each and
every one of our panel um award winers
perhaps one or two in one or two
sentences what advice can you give to
our young
designers to inspire them maybe Brian
would you like to start um I I I think I
would just go back to what I was saying
earlier that it's very important to be
to be proactive and and optimistic about
um the constraints and the conditions
that you're given to work with because
ultimately it's a it's a labor of love
and and optimism and faith in the
future
sh um don't take everything so
seriously
I'm still trying to do that but that's
the advice I give
myself yeah I I think one of the things
that we've learned specifically from
this project is just um kind of the
power of empathy as part of the
architect School toolkit just to really
um try to you know we all we all like to
impose our kind of design concept on
something I think sometimes to kind of
hold that back for a little while longer
and think a little bit more about uh who
is going to be the how they're going to
experience it and and what ultimately
the encounter with that work of design
will mean to them right yeah so so I've
been I mean I'm 43 now right so I'm just
thinking like so so what what's
happiness right and and this job this
this job at where where I am to continue
to give me happiness right so so I've
done my my research right so happiness
are two things right you death bit you
need remember two things one one is the
life experiences you had you know you
know oh oh my grandkid so cute so cute
and then the other one the the other one
are the quality of relationships so
therefore how does everything that I do
in my life including work support qu
quity relationships I'm I'm not signing
out for sh relationships I only want to
work with good people and po stop
yeah
um
um I think uh be
courageous and be um
persistent and enjoy the
process and
um yeah don't give up as a designer I I
think um not until the building or the
architecture is
realized n out of 10 people don't know
what you're talking about thank
you well in closing uh I saw the title
for this forum people at heart and I
think that's something that resonates
very well with me uh and my uh
encouragement to Young designers uh at
the end of the day uh practicing thing
is very highly complex uh today all the
more but not let us not forget that uh
the purpose in what we do is for the
people at the end of the day yeah so
that's my takeway and advice well said
well a big congratulations to all our
white iners thank
you keep inspiring and we look forward
to bigger things from all of you and
thank you Yori for having me and thank
you for the
session
thanks for the sharing today we have
reached the end of part one of the
president's design award 2023 recipients
Forum I would like to request for the
audience to stay and take a group photo
I would also like to invite our speakers
to take their seats with the
audience
right